[Musique]
nous sommes en banlieue de miami dans
cette église à moitié remplie de fidèles
l'évêque remercie dieu qui a installé
donald trump à la maison blanche
ganley or comment de ranchi l'événement
est organisé par le groupe évangélique
pour tron tout le bye bye le clou du
spectacle ou de la cérémonie l'un des
fils du président eric trump en profite
pour mettre en garde contre les
démocrates qui présumément infligerait
les pires maux à la chrétienté
après le lancer de casquettes aux
couleurs du président en pleine église
les fidèles nous confie à la sortie
qu'ils voteront évidemment pour le
président un homme de foi
mais les évangéliques ne pense pas tous
de la même façon
en fait le pasteur joël enter vient de
cosigner aux côtés de 1600 leaders
religieux
une lettre qui invite les chrétiens à
voter pour joe biden dessus même s'il a
voté pour donald trump
il ya quatre ans dans ce message les
chefs de file évangéliques sont prêtes à
mettre entre parenthèses leurs objectifs
essentiels empêcher l'avortement a tout
pris une décision difficile est chiche
le pasteur évangélique dogues padgett
encourage les électeurs qui ont la foi à
se prononcer partout au pays
pas question d'influencés ceux qui
votent aux abords des bureaux de scrutin
juste tenter de stopper la réélection du
président républicain
nous l'avons rejoint dans son autobus de
l'amour qui a déjà parcouru plus de 145
mille kilomètres d'est en ouest et il
n'est pas très tendre avec donald
travailler en ce sens les actes parlent
plus que les mots selon lui
un beau cadeau pour les évangéliques ont
vu en donald trump un rempart contre
l'avortement
le pasteur hunter ne pense pas qu'ils
ont encore besoin de lui et me disent
c'est le grand espoir de doc magic qui a
sondé les catholiques blanc et les
évangéliques dans les états pivots les
plus importants là où les écarts
d'intentions de vote entre bayonne et
rome sont plutôt faibles
[Applaudissements]
ces prières et promesses des partisans
du président qui selon eux a été élu par
dieu seront elles entendues
pour l'instant les voies du seigneur
restent impénétrables
[Musique]